twitter is something that came about uh
in 2006 and just you know blew people
away but nobody has really uh I guess it
hasn't it hasn't entered the mainstream
conscious consciousness until really
this last year or so and it's just
what's crazy is a people like autumn re
are now twittering instead of
vlogging and it's it's just this great
way to be concise get your ideas out
there and connect with people in ways
that you never would whether it be
politicians or celebrities or just your
friends I absolutely adore the medium i
also love facebook i use them equally
and i think it makes it less an email is
something that is a bit more personal
you feel like maybe you need to really
work out a response or spend some more
time on it Twitter and Facebook it's
like you can jot out one line you know
one line messages to people and connect
with them even quicker than email even
though you could also do that with email
it removes kind of the fear of getting
in touch with someone so as you know a
phone call might be even more personal
than email takes a back one notch and
Twitter and Facebook take it back
another notch so it's it's just a way to
connect with people that you would never
be either know their email addresses or
feel comfortable emailing with and that
makes it just absolutely terrific
I probably would never in my life
communicated with Shaq or Jimmy fat well
maybe I would have interacted with Jimmy
Fallon but or who else I mean Barack
Obama's Barack Obama's on Twitter not
that he's you know sending me direct
messages but anyone anyone that you can
imagine is out there and yeah it's just
it's overwhelming almost still to me
it's just I can't believe that that I
can get in touch with someone like Demi
Moore on Twitter who knew who knew and
and and the fact that they're so
down-to-earth a lot of a lot of the
celebrities that are on Twitter and they
are genuinely I feel there to connect
with people that are fans of theirs and
aren't just promoting what new you know
movie they're in or whatever they're
taking back their identities and I see
that as extremely positive especially in
a tabloid culture Lance Armstrong
especially he always talks about that
how it's like well you think i was there
at this time with this person actually
why don't you check my Twitter I'll go
back and look and see where i was i was
eating a ham sandwich at home getting
ready for whatever you know cycle ride i
was about to take so yeah it's a really
really a way to take back your identity
for a public figure
I use Twitter and Facebook as both a way
to get my content out and also a way to
just communicate with people and then my
favorite way of using social networking
is to query I will go out and ask
whether it be a professional thing like
asking an Amanda on the street question
or I recently went up to Big Sur and I
hadn't had time to do any research and I
just asked what should i do in Big Sur
who's you know who knows who knows what
I'm going to get but it ended up being
one of the best vacations ever because I
got some really informed answers and I
spent three seconds writing my Twitter
message and getting the answers and all
I had to bring up was my iphone and I
was set
well I think a subscription model works
for some for some content I think it
works better for extremely niche content
a small subscriber count at you know 10
or even five dollars a month even if you
know you only have ten thousand people
watching or so that's going to bring you
a pretty decent income however for for
content that is a bit broader and
perhaps more mainstream I think that the
free model works better advertising
works better sponsorship works better
product placement works better i'm a fan
of you know a five-second pre-roll just
saying sometimes daily sponsored by it's
it's it's a it's a really quick way of
getting out you know the thank you to
your sponsor you don't need 30 seconds
to explain your product people are going
to get it or not and connect with it or
not within five to eight seconds so why
torture the rest of the people that are
watching and hammer it into their heads
whatever you're doing you're actually
only annoying them
you